buenas tardes buenas tardes
tarde estar bien
así y hoy vamos a hablar de como siempre
del inglés del aprendizaje de idiomas
y ya
[Música]
no me dejaron
sí
a sol a sol a sol a sol
y ya
eso
no soy yo
hay muchos muchos ejemplos por ejemplo
el inglés si se escribe
con él rm se pronuncia como o are the
world en la mansión sound iberworld the
hardy es lo mismo no sé si pero en
español no no en español es más lógico
creo que sí que este es uno de los
grandes problemas que si leemos el
inglés en español lo leemos y se
pronuncia en inglés no entonces creo que
es uno de los problemas que o
dificultades que tenemos los españoles
al aprender el inglés sí y por eso que
tienes que escuchar mucho yo escucho la
misma cosa voy a escuchar como diez y
quince y veinte veces entonces entonces
las palabras en este contenido no son
las palabras que yo he leído son las
palabras que he oído a escuchado
entonces esta impresión del sonido es
más importante
y después lo puedo ver lo leo porque es
él
sentido de lo que estoy leyendo pero la
pronuncia viene del audio sí creo que el
sistema español para aprender idiomas
han focalizado mucho en la gramática sí
y creo que una de las cosas que
proporcionar link es que no los finales
escuchar y leer y con esta metodología
porque creo que es mejoramos mucho más
la pronunciación sí
absolutamente y también la gramática se
puede uno puede pensar que está
aprendiendo la gramática las reglas de
la gramática pero no finalmente
este se pierde muy rápidamente pero si
se hace
como dice costumbres y hábitos hábitos
bueno si sea de hábitos pues no tienes
que pensar a la gramática vas a hablar
como fluido fluido
yo ya no voy a ser el siguiente en
weezer walsh año pensión fox and
internationa del ritmo del idioma porque
cada cada idioma tiene su ritmo el
francés y también el español de españa y
en el ritmo es diferente del español de
méxico por serlo de argentina o de lo
que sea entonces el ritmo es muy
importante y hay maneras
modos para practicar
por ejemplo escuchar y escuchar y leer y
después leer
grabar su voz después de 15 lo hace lo
hace cada día durante una semana una
expresión una frase y tentar de imitar
el ritmo y con el mismo viene la
pronuncia de la pronuncia y también
las frases los tras las tras las frases
porque para para hablar en un ritmo
natural tienes que utilizar las frases y
si tú haces frases de tipo español bueno
es que va a cambiar el ritmo ya lo que
creo que también es uno de mis grandes
errores que al final sin querer quieres
buscar la traducción al español pero al
final no se construye igual la espalda
las frases no entonces creo que también
es un buen consejo no de que al final no
intentemos traducir y si no aprendemos
las frases completas del idioma no no
palabra por palabra soy hacía porque no
es palabra por palabra final lo que
están haciendo es traducir sino entender
el concepto no de la frase de cómo se
habla en el idioma si entonces tienes
que escuchar mucho tienes que fugarse en
las frases
en el ritmo y si tienes el ritmo
correcto pero las frases la pronuncia
todo esto va a venir
sin pensar
leiter
weinstein de monsters
one
por 17 varios sábados recomendado for
international of stars with an american
in english american inglés no
en el link
[Música]